our state's covid response team
addressed the numbers today they say
delayed
laboratory reporting is causing low
totals and numbers will increase
tomorrow they also talked about contact
tracing and mentioned that neither the
uk variant
nor the south african variant have been
detected here in nevada
as for a discussion on the vaccine mega
sites like the cashman center
covett response director caleb cage says
they are pleased with how it is
developing
we're well within that process as you
know governor susak recently announced
that he
has directed state leadership agency
state agencies such as emergency
management in the national guard
to provide planning support and resource
support to help the local
district there are limited resources
in in vaccination in the vaccination
process but also in the testing process
and so as with any emergency where we
have
limited resources which in my
experiences is every
emergency we will have to make decisions
the local
local jurisdiction will have to make
decisions
on what their needs are well caleb cage
added that governor sysalek wants to
maintain the testing focus
at places such as the catchment center
but will also get the vaccine
distributed
as well